I'm Neil Gershenfeld I direct the center
for hits and atoms at MIT we do research
at the boundary of physical science and
computer science one of the core things
were working on is how do you make the
Star Trek replicator how do you put
codes into materials to arrange atoms
and that's maybe a 20 year research
roadmap it's recreating the history of
computing from mainframes to mini
computers to pcs and so along the way
we've developed community field fab labs
and machines that make machines and
they're being used for the equivalent of
inventing the internet anybody makes
anything it cuts right across the
boundaries of aid education industry
leads to new educational models new
business models new aide models so the
form has been a wonderful setting to
explore with leaders in each of those
areas how to build that kind of
organizational capacity the most
exciting thing here is the forums done a
quite an adventurous experiment of right
on the terrace in the Congress Center
setting up a fab lab I suggested rather
than having me just talk about it we
should have the lab so we have a lab
here running with a team from around the
world running it so people can see and
do all of this I don't believe that's
ever been done and it's been wonderfully
gratifying people coming with all sorts
of backgrounds with all sorts of ideas
actually getting that hands-on
experiment experience to help lead this
revolution